hey we're the fast food friends and
today we're gonna be trying chef gordon
ramsay's airfryer steak recipe
all right so we got aleppo pepper and
then we got
coffee grounds this nice rib eye steak
i'm gonna mix together the aleppo pepper
and the coffee now we're just making a
rub so i'm going to put equal parts
coffee and pepper in there
how spicy is it
[Music]
he says to put the rub on the plate
first that's what i'm going to do
massage the meat there a little shiatsu
going
make sure you get all the edges chef
ramsay says to make sure to preheat your
air fryer to 390 for at least three
minutes
i'm gonna put it in and let it cook for
eight to ten minutes
it's only been a couple minutes since i
put in the airfryer but already it's
smelling like
coffee and pepper up in here i just want
to say i don't know if you can hear this
but it's sizzling and i'm getting hungry
sizzle baby
oh my goodness gracious look at that
holy guacamole look at the steak
are we kidding look at that that's not
what i was expecting is that what you
were expecting
then we're just gonna transfer it to our
cutting board
and every chef knows you let your steak
rest for at least 10 minutes
so i'm just going to put this little
foil over it so it doesn't get too cold
and then we'll come back in about 10
minutes and let it rest i'm going to cut
it and see what it looks like
okay oh it's nice and soft i wanted
a little bit of pink wow wow wow
look at this steak this is insane
i like my sticks medium rare this looks
a little bit more
cooked here we go look at that bad boy
first bite
[Music]
whoa damn corn ramsay i am pleased
is it a really good charred taste it is
very very good
honestly i feel like mine came out
slightly overcooked it's not
as like tender as a you know medium
medium rare steak this thing is
mega flavorful the pepper and the coffee
go perfectly gives it like
more of an earthy taste this was two
steps
put seasoning on steak put steak in
airfry that's all you gotta do
this is insane i do miss a little bit
of the salt content that i would usually
have if i seasoned it the way i
typically do
that being said i can't stop eating here
i think overall
this was really good very delicious i'm
gonna be air frying steaks all the time
now that's gonna become a regular thing
it's gordon ramsay so i feel like we
should have known that it was
gonna be pretty good gordon ramsay i
think you're a baby
i'm gonna go ahead and give my steak a
8 out of 10. this is easily a score of
9.5 out of 10. if this was medium rare
y'all try it at home let us know in the
comments what you think i just want to
air fry everything now
you